so good evening switzerland and the
european union
are more than just neighbors we have
very close and deep ties rooted in a
long
shared european history geographical
proximity plays a role of course but
much more important
are the close bonds between our citizens
about 1.4 million european citizens
live in switzerland and 450 000
swiss live in the european union another
320
000 european citizens crossed the border
daily
to work in switzerland the citizens of
switzerland have shown today
that they value these ties
they their vote upholds one of the core
pillars
of our relationship the mutual freedom
to move to live and to work in
switzerland
and the european union i welcome this
outcome
i see it as a positive signal to
continue to consolidate
and deepen our relationship
i would soon speak to mrs omaruga the
president of the swiss confederation
i will congratulate her on this result
of course i look forward to the swiss
federal council
now moving swiftly on the signature and
ratification
of the international framework agreement
that we negotiated in 2018
i will reiterate this message i passed
last january when we met in davos